[موسيقى]
يقال اضحك عليها تنجلي فمن الاهداف
الاساسيه للضحك التنفيس اي التعبير عن
المكبوت وتكسير البوهات قد يتمت ع كل
البشر بالقدره على الضحك لكنهم لا يضحكون
على نفس الدعابات تتغير النكات من بقعه
جغرافيه الى اخرى وتتلون بالثقافه السائده
في كل مجتمع او
دوله لكن حين تتحول النكته الى سلاح تصبح
مزعجه وحين تختلط النكته بما هو محرم قد
تصبح مرفوضه ومحظور اخر حلقه من برنامجنا
لهذا العام اخترنا ان نناقش خلالها
التابوهات في عالم الفكاهه فما هي
المواضيع التي لا تزال محرمه في فلك
الممنوع في بلاد العرب كل شيء مقدس الا
الانسان انت زمك تصك وانت مالزم تحكي حك
وزمك تغزر حك وزمك تعمل حك وزمك تلبس حكش
في شي محظورات
العمر تبوه انا موضوع الهومو سكوتي بحسه
موضوع تبوه كثير بلبنان مواضيع زي هيك
يعني هي مش موجوده بمجتمعنا ولو كانت
موجوده فهي بنسبه ضئيله لكن عم تتضخم بشكل
كبير لم تستحي افعل ما شئت يعني بطل حدا
يستحي كله صار ينحكى فيه تابو ولا يجب
التطرق اليها هي المواضيع الدينيه والم
دكه في المقدس بقوه وقت اللي انسان يمسك
في الدين اعك يمسك في كرامتك يمسك في شخصك
فهمتني يمسك في العقيده بعك
السياسه الطلاق
ديفورس لا سس ما تنجمش تحكي فيها مع راجلك
تقول انا نحب كذا و نحب كذا ولا محليك تعم
هك في في دنيا اخرى هك و ما تنجمش يعني
الانسان بكل شيء بحياته لازم ي يعني ي
يحكي فيه لحد معين ما تحررنا بض مع الاسف
تعددت الاسماء وكثرت الممنوعات تجاوزت الى
الدين الى الرموز الى بعض العناوين
التاريخيه صراحه به المجتمع صار كل شيء
منحكى ممكن في شغله رافضها بخصوص موضوع ال
حقوق المساواه بما انها خلينا نحكي طلعت
عن حدودها شوي كل شيء تبوه حسب الشخص سك
الزوج المدني المعتقدات الدينيه
الشخوص السياسيه المراه تكون متحرره جنسيا
او حتى عيض او هيك قصص هون بحث كثير تابو
هناك دائما حدود ومعايير لهذه الافكار
والمعتقدات هلا ما بقى في شيء كل شيء مباح
صار ينحكى فيه هلا هلا حاليا بهالايام كل
شيء اكثر من قصه الجيز وما الجيز وه القصص
وصار يعني جهوريا علنيا ما بحدا مستحي لا
ننقض الملك والملك يفعل ما يشاء ونحن
نعاني عليش ما نقدرش ملك خ
فرهد الفكاهه والنكات في فلك الممنوع
وحلقه خاصه فيها اقوى اللحظات وضيوف
اختاروا فن الدعابه والكوميديا كمهنه
للتعبير عن افكار ومواضيع منها ما هو تابو
سابدا من هنا من الاستديو في باريس ارحب
بالفنان الكوميدي السوداني مصطفى جري اهلا
بك مصطفى اهلا مصطفى يعني يعني ما رايك
بهذه العينه اليوم هناك الكثير من
المواضيع التابو في المجتمعات العربيه
وكيف تتعامل مع البوهات في نصوصك وفي
عروضك الكوميديه
ا اول حاجه شكرا على انه يعني نحنا ناسي
الحاجه الثانيه بالنسبه لي التابوهات
بتختلف من مكان لمكان لكن في ثلاثه حاجات
نحنا بشترك عليها في الوطن في الوطن
العربي اللي هو مثلث التابوهات يعني اللي
بيدخل فيه الجنس والسياسه والدين بتختلف
بعدك من كل مكان لمكان بالنسبه لنا نحنا
في السودان المثلث اضيق شويه كيف يعني
بيدخل فيه المجتمع وخياراته يعني المجتمع
ما بيحب يتكلم عن حاجات كثيره جدا يعني
حتى مثلا العنصريه ما بيتكلم عنها اللي هي
ما بتدخل ما بتدخل في الدين ولا السياسه
ولا الجنس بتدخل في تعامل الناس مع بعضهم
البعض لو اتكلمت عنها بيحسوا انه انت كده
بتشق الصف و يعني داير داير تفرق المجتمع
يعني مادر مادر تخلي الناس عندها عباره
بتخرب النسيج المجتمعي عرفتي حتى في الضحك
يعني لا يمكن ان نضحك عليها هذه بالضبط هي
النقطه انه في مواضيع هم بياخدوها بجديه
شديده فبيقول انه ما ممكن اضحك فيها اصلا
اللي انا بالنسبه لي يعني ده ده هورا يعني
بالنسبه لاي شي ممكن اضحك فيه بعد ذاك
بيعتمد انه كيف هنضحك فيه تمام ودي الحاجه
اللي انا يعني بتخليني بحب الفن اللي انا
بقدمه ده انه ممكن تتكلم في اي شي تقريبا
بس لو لقيت الطريقه المناسبه لقيت المدخل
المناسب بعد داك بتقول انه هو هزار يعني
يعني تراعي هناك مداخل معينه هناك سنتحدث
عن هذه المراعاه بعد قليل دعنا نتعرف على
باقي الضيوف من مونبولي عبر سكايب الفنان
الكوميدي الجزائري اسماعيل اسماعيل بالحين
اهلا بك يا اسماعيل اسماعيل هل تضع خطوطا
حمراء لنفسك عندما تكتب النصوص الكوميديه
خاصه عندما يتعلق الامر بالتبت او الامور
المحظوره اجتماعيا شكرا جزيلا على
نعم بض الخطوط
الحمراء منح نرح ناس
ولكن عندي مبادئ وعندي قضايا و وفي
المبادئ والقضايا
تعي نسي نطرق عليها مهما لو جرحت ناس اخرى
ولكن تناور
تناور عندي دقه باش ما نجرح من ولكن هما
هذا من ذكاء الممثل
نعم يعني اسماعيل انت وجدت خطوط للمناوره
ربما كي تتحدث بهذه المواضيع بشكل غير
مباشر او بشكل مباشر ولكن هناك التجربه مع
ضيفتنا الاخيره ربما مختلفه قليلا عن
تجربتك في هذا الاطار من بيروت عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه الفنانه الكوميديه
والنشطه الكوريه شادن فقيه اهلا بك يا
شادن شادن انت يعني في
الكثير من الفكاهه التي تكسرت بشكل مباشر
هل تتعمدين استخدام النكته كسلاح لتكسير
البهات وهل يوتك هذا الامر في مشاكل مع
الحضور احيانا او بالمطلق مع المجتمع او
مع الراي العام اول شي بدي اقوللكم شكرا
للاستضافه لانه كلهم قالوا لكم سو ما بدي
اطلع
بالاخلاق سو شكرا
للاستضافه اما
بموضوع كوميديا كسلاح اكيد يعني ال الحكي
على طول كل حياته الحكي والفن ام كان
والكتابه وكل هول المواضيع كانوا سلاح
وانا اكيد بعتبره سلاح واكيد بطرق
للمواضيع مواضيع تعتبر تبوه بس هي اساسيه
ينحكى فيها ان كان موضوع المعتقدات
الدينيه او الممارسات الدينيه ان كان
السكس ان كان مواضيع سياسيه او المقامات
السياسيه الالهيه كلها والمواضيع انا
بعتبر الكوميديا هي وسيله كثير قويه ت
تنتقد وتسخر يعني بمحلات معينه انا بعتقد
انه في قوه للكوميديا اللي هي بترجع اذا
بدك خلينا نحكي مثلا عن مقامات الرئاسات
بالعالم العربي وكل هول لما انت تنكتي
عليهم انت عم ترجعيه لانه هو انسان يعني
منه
مقام ايه يعني الكوميديا هي وسيله مهمه
يعني انا كيف بنظر للواقع انا بعتبر
انه المجتمع
مسرحيه مسرحيه في في لها سكريبت في امرار
بيسمحوا لك تخرج من النص طالما انت مش عم
تعملي شيء اي برات الفكره الاساسيه يعني
كلنا بمثل بتروحي انت على كريسمس بتروحي
انت بتمثلي مع عائلتك كل الناس بتمثل
بالشغل بمثل وهول انا رافضه هالفكره انا
رافضه حتى امثل انه في انسان برئاسه
الجمهوريه مثل المسرحيه اللي هم عاطيني
اياها لانه انت بدك تركعي له كل هيدا انا
ما بحب انا انا اكتي على المسرح بحب اعيش
الحقيقه يعني الحياه مسرحيه هي كلها عن جد
كلنا بنمثل على
بعض ما حدا بكي حقيقته ما
حدا ايه المسارح اللي انا انا المسرحيه
اللي انا بدي اعملها هي الحقيقه بدي انا
اكسر فكره انه في الكذب والتمثيل على بعض
انا بدي احكي عن كل المواضيع اللي كلنا
بنعيشها اللي كلنا بنفكر فيها اللي كلنا
بنسها بنسال اسئله يعني انا عملت انترفيو
على الل بي سي اي مع مع رودولف وكنت عم
بحضرها مع ماما للانترفيو وبمحض
معين بينحكى عن موضوع الهومو سكشوال تي
وبيجي بيقول لي انه كل النصوص الدينيه
بتقول انه هيدا الشيء خاطئ سوري في هلا
احكي عن هالموضوع او بدك بعدين سنتحدث هذه
هي الفقره المقبله سنتحدث عن هذا الموضوع
يعني في هذه الحلقه شادن والضيوف
اخترنا ان نعود على بعض اقوى لحظات من
برنامجنا لعام 2023 سابدا مع هذا المقطع
جول خولي هو اول اعلامي من اصول عربيه
يعلن عن مثليته الجنسيه نستمع اليه معا
ومن ثم نناقش لانني اعيش في واشنطن دي سي
في العاصمه في بلد عندما وصلت اليه عرفت
الفرق بين الحب وخطاب الكراهيه التي عشت
معظم حياتي اتلقاه واكره نفسي وبالتالي
كان علي
هذا هذه المسؤوليه ان اكسر حاجز هذا الخوف
كما كسرته عند وصولي الى هنا وان اقول لمن
يريد ان يسمع بان لي ما في اي شيء غلط ليس
هناك اي خطا في الاشخاص المثليين لان هذه
كانت فكره منم كنت اعتقد فيها وبالتالي
عندما درست اكثر عن الموضوع في الدين في
التاريخ في العلم وجدت ان هذا الموضوع كان
موجودا في كل الحضرات السابقه واي دين هو
حق مشروع لكل الاشخاص ان يكون معتقدهم
ولكن ليس هناك حق للاخرين ان يمارسوا هذا
الدين للتمييز ضد الاخرين نعم سادعك
تكملين الفكره شادن انك بدات بالحديث عن
المثليه الجنسيه التي لا تزال تبو في
الكثير من المجتمعات هل تعتبرين ان
الفكاهه سعدتك اكثر على التعبير عن هذا
الموضوع يعني على مستوى خاص ومستوى عام
ربما اوكي سو حاحكي عده قصص سو كنت انا
وماما عدين وعم نحضر الانترفيو مع رودولف
على ال بي سي وبمحض معين بيقوللي انه كل
الاديان بتعارض المثليه وهون انا جيت قلت
انه ومين انا ومين بيقول انه انا بامن
بهيدا الدين او بهيدا الدين يعني الناس
بتامن باديان معينه وبعتبرها هي الحقيقه
المطلقه وبدهم يطبقوا هيدا الدين عليك
وهيدا بعتقد اللي اللي قاله شو اسمه اللي
هلا مش وا حكي
هلا اللي قاله جو يعني انه انت بحق لك
تامن بدينك بس مين قال لك انه انا بامن به
الدين اي انا يمكن بامن بغير شيء وما يعني
دينك هو الحقيقه المطلقه هيدي من جهه من
جه ثانيه بمحل معين هون وقت انا جيت قلت
انه انا ما بامن بالاديان رودولف انه سال
انه كيف يعني ما بتامن انه ما في الله وما
في هيك هون قلت له انه بدك نحكي بالوجود
انه وسالت السؤال انه طيب اوكي اذا الله
خلق الكم مين خلق الله وهون امي خبطت يا
مشحر يا ان انه انت هلا كفرتي على التي في
اللبناني وهيدي بحق لهم يحبسوك وانا لي
انا ما كفرت انا ليترلي سالت سؤال كل
الناس على التسع سنين يعني مش ما في حدود
ما في حدود في اسئلتك شادن يعني لا يعني
ليس هناك كما يقال مكياج احيان حدود ام
ولد عمره تسع سنين اول سؤال بيساله انه
مين من وين جينا نحن بيجوا بقولوا له
الاهل الله بييجوا بيسال الولد مين خلق
الله بيقولوا لك لا ستوب هير عرفتي طيب
يعني انا اللي قلته على التي في هو منه
كفر هو تساؤل موجود عند كل الناس يعني هذه
ارائك وانت تطرحين بشكل مباشر ربما في
نصوصك الدينيه في نصوصك عفوا
شو اسمه الكوميديه اريد ان اسال بالعوده
الى يعني مساله التبو
والفكاهه مصطفى شادن يعني ما في شيء عندها
تبو يعني تخرج من هذا الاطار تماما على
قاعده ان هذه تساؤلات محقه ويحق لاي شخص
ان يتساءل ما يريد هناك الكثير من ال
النكات التي تتطرق الى مسائل تبو منها
المثليه الجنسيه ولكن بشكل مسيء يعني هناك
كوميديين اليوم او فنانين كوميديين وفنان
يضحكون على المثليه الجنسيه ولكن بشكل
مسيء اليوم هل تعتبر انت ان الدعابه او
الكوميديا يجب ان تلتزم بسقف اخلاقي معين
وفق المجتمع الذي تتواجد به لكي تكون
مضحكه او رائجه او
مقبوله طيب يعني مضحكه ما بالضروره مرادف
لراي ج و مقبوله ام وكونها هي مضحكه
بالنسبه لشخص ما معناتها هي مضحكه بالنسبه
لكل الناس الثانيين يعني نظريا انا ممكن
اتفق معك بس يعني اعتباطا انه
نحنا مفروض يكون عندنا سقف اخلاقي وكذا
لكن بعدك حندخل في سؤال انه من اللي بيحدد
السقف الاخلاقي يعني اذا نحنا افترضنا من
جهه انه المفروض ن احنا ما نضحك على بعض
المجتمعات المتحده سواء كان السود سواء
كان المثليين سواء كان المراه دي كلها ناس
ننا المفروض ما نعمل عليها نكات فمعناته
احنا بنفترق انه الناس الثانيين اللي هم
الناس اللي بيقولوا انه عادي بنضحك على
الحاجات دي لكن عندهم بخطوا الخط عندهم في
الدين بفتر انهم هم عندهم الحق ده برض
يعني انهم يقولوا اننا ما ضحك على الدين
الكلام ده كله ليه عشان اصل في النقطه
النهائيه انه الجمهور هو اللي بيحدد هو
عايز يسمع شنو ولا ما عايز يسمع شنو بعد
داك انت كفنان بتختار انت عايز تتكلم مع
جمهور يعني انا ما هجبر الناس كلهم يجوا
يدخلوا القاعه عشان يسمعوا العرض بتاعي
وال الموضوع بسيط يعني زي لما انك تمشي
تشتري قميص من دكان بتشوف القمصان كلها
اللي ما بيعجبك ما بتشيله بتمشي سيد المحل
بتقول له ده شنو القميص يعني لا تلزم نفسك
انت تقدم تلزم الناس انت بتلزم نفسك بكل
باخلاقك انت بتختار بصلتك الاخلاقيه بتبني
على نصوصك لانه كونه يكون في نكه اوفنسيف
مثلا ممكن انت تشوفها اوفنسيف حتى انت ك
كوميديان انا مثلا كمصطفى ما حصل شفت نكته
كانت اوفنسيف بالنسبه لي يعني ل هناك بعض
النكات التي سخرت احيانا من ذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه التي يعني هناك بعض
القضايا في العالم التي صدمت على قاعده ان
انه لا يمكن ان نسخر من اي شيء او من كل
شيء سنكمل في هذا الحديث ساسال اسماعيل
اسماعيل هناك ايضا مساله اين كما قال
مصطفى او من هو الجمهور يعني انت تقدم
عروضا في فرنسا وسبق وقدمت في الجزائر
وربما في دول اخرى هل
يتغير المحتوى من مكان الى اخر هل تشعر
احيانا انك هناك ازدواجيه ربما في التعامل
مع المواضيع خاصه البهات في النص الكوميدي
لا يمكن ان تقدم ما تقدمه في فرنسا كما
تقدمه في دول اخرى باريز بينس و
اخر ما
تفوت في
مكان الناس عندهم معتقدات
بوليتيك من
اليمين ساعه افت نلعب في مكان
اخر اخر مع ناس ليهم معتقدات
بيسار وتشوف الناس تحك كيف كيف
نعم هذا هل يضع عليك قيود اسماعيل في نصك
يعني عندما تكتب النص تفكر الى من انت
تتوجه كما قال مصطفى منذ
قليل انا عندي اناحب
الك مجانيه ولكن عندما اتكلم على مبادئي
وعلى قضايا
النفسيه
اتعب لان بالنسبه لي فنان يكون عنده يكون
عنده شخصيه وما هي النكته المجانيه
بالنسبه اليك ما هي النكات المجانيه
بالنسبه النكته المجانيه هي النكته اللي
تجرح ناس وما عندها اي بعد لتجرح الناس
هذه بالنسبه لي
ما تعالج اي اي
قضيه تجرح ناس ولا تعالج اي قضيه سي هذ
نكته مجانيه شاد توافقين على مساله النكته
المجانيه يعني النكته المجانيه
ليست لا قيمه لها خاصه عندما تكون في
مواضيع حساسه ربما بوافق مليون بالم اللي
قاله انا انا بزيد علي فكره انه انا بامن
انه بال بنهايه المطاف انت شخص عم تحكي مع
جمهور يعني انت في رساله عم توصل يعني انت
عندك
مسؤوليه انا ما بعتبر في خطوط حمر انا بع
بعتبر ها يو هاندل يعني كيف انت بتاخذي
هالموضوع وبتحلي وبتشتغلي عليه يعني كل
المواضيع بحق له الواحد يحكي عنها بس مش
على حساب حدا ثاني وعلى حساب حدا ثاني
يعني ما يكون في تحريض ما يكون في ولكن هل
يمكن ان نضحك على كل شيء يا شاد نتحدث عن
كل المواضيع نعم ولكن في مساله الضحك هناك
هذه الفك يعني اليوم قد يسال البعض هل
يمكن ان يضحك على الموت على الماسي على
امور ربما تدخل اطار السخريه السوداء انا
حفت لك انا كن سويه
مثلا انه انا اليوم بعتبر انه نحن اليوم
فينا نعمل نكت خاصه بالاغتصاب طالما منا
نكته مجانيه يعني منا على حساب الضحيه
وطالما عم نيجي نقول فكره مننا ام عرفت
كيف اي طالما في هدف منه انا هي راي
الشخصي يعني في ناس بتعتبر انه ما ضروري
يكون في هدف انا طبعي انه انا لا بحس انه
عندي مسؤوليه وانا حلي وعم بحكي عن
الموضوع ما بدي احكي وزدته هيك بالهواء
بدي احكي واحطه باطار معين وقتها يسمع
الجمهور شي يفهم انه انا وقت عم بحكي عن
الاغتصاب انا مش عم سخف الاغتصاب اولا ومش
عم بضحك على الاغتصاب انا عم بضحك على
مثلا المتعدي على المغتصب على المجتمع شو
قال عرفتي بطريقه كوميديه ف مش على حساب
الضحيه
انا وهي مساله تعامل ربما مع البهات
المتعلقه بالنساء بشكل خاص في مساله
الفكاهه ساعود اليك مصطفى دعنا فقط ان
نشاهد يعني هناك هذا هذا الموضوع الذي
يحمل في طياته مئات البوهات النساء وحقوق
النساء والمساواه وما الى هنالك في هذا
الاطار نستمع الى ما قاله الباحث والمتخصص
في علم وتاريخ الاديان والحضارات القديمه
خز عل الماجدي لبرنامج في فرك الممنوع هذا
الكلام المعسول النظري لا يقدم ولا ينفع
بكل صراحه اقول سنبقى نردده الى الاف
السنوات القادمه ثم ماذا اين هي الحقوق
الحقيقيه للمراه اين هي حريه المراه اين
هي تفاصيل دقيقه واين لا توجد غير موجوده
خذي شوفي انظري الى افغانستان
كدوله يعني فاشله النساء فيها القابعات في
البيوت المنع من التعليم هذ هذه هي
النتيجه الطبيعيه فيما بعد انظري كل
الحقيقه كل الذي حصل هو ضد المراه بكل
صراحه اقول المراه كائن لا يختلف عن الرجل
مطلقا له كل الحقوق وله كل كل ما يجب ان
ياله الرجل لكن الرجل استولى على المؤسسات
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والدينيه عبر
التاريخ فهمش المراه ودمرها وكان هي عدوته
وليست منجبه يعني مصطفى الفكاهه عندما
تتناول النساء وحقوق النساء تكرس احيانا
كثيره لصور نمطيه عن النساء تعزز احيانا
خطاب تمييزي هل هذا يدخل ضمن اطار النكات
المجانيه برايك وهل انت عندما تكتب نصا
فكاهيا عن يعني النساء او يعني المراه في
مكان ما هل
تفكر كيف ستحارب التنميط ام انك تفكر فقط
في فكاهه النص طيب ا بالنسبه لي في نوعين
يعني يا اما انا بكتب النكته دي لنفسي انا
بضحكني يعني يا اما انا بكتب النكته
للجمهور يعني انا اذا بكتب النكته للجمهور
ما بتذكر اخر مره متين اصلا عملت نكته
بتطرق للمراه سواء كان بشكل
مسيء او يعني باي شكل فيه فيه هجوم يعني
لانه بشوف يعني يعني الحاجه دي ما حتونا
لقدام حتا خرنا بس يعني ما هيكون في فرق
بين كوميديان في 2023 وكوميديا في 1960
يعني يعني دي بالنسبه لي حاجه بتكون بتاع
زول الكوميديان المفصل عن الواقع اصلا انا
قضيت لي اخترتها في البدايه انه باعتبار
انه انا سوداني لما طلعت من السودان
اكتشفت انه العالم ما بيعرف عن السودان
حاجه اخترت انه خلاص ده الخط اللي انا
حمشي فيه اللي هو الحرب الحاصله في
السودان الناس اللي بتموت في السودان اللي
هم فوقهم يعني الاف وملايين النساء
بيعانوا يعني بيكونوا المستهدف الاول لاي
جريمه بترتب في السودان اول حاجه تحصل
بتكون النساء هم اللي بضرر يعني بنوصل
لانه مثلا الناس في هيدي الحاجه درسها انه
النساء في السودان بيفتشوا مثلا في فوض
صحيه لانه بيكون في حصار على المدن وفي
يعني المستشفيات بتتقص ودكاكين بتقفل
وصيدليات بتتسرق فبي جي بيطلع زول بيقول
انه الناس في شنو وت في شنو تمام فدي
عباره عن تقليل للمعاناه بتاع النساء دي
مما بدات تاريخ الذكوري ده فكونه انا
بمجرد ما اني انا اخترت انه انا اتكلم في
الموضوع ده ما بشوف انه انا اصلا عندي
خيار بتاع انه اقلل من هايه الموضوع او
اسخف منه زي ما قالت على العكس ربما اليوم
هناك الكثير من الدراسات التي يعني تجري
على مساله فن الكوميديا ستاند اب كوميدي
كما
تفعلون يعني ساسال اسماعيل في هذا الاطار
اليوم هناك فنانات وفنانين في كل العالم
يحاولون تغيير الواقع فيما يتعلق بالتابوت
عبر هذا النوع من الكوميديا مثلا في فرنسا
مساله الدوره الشهريه لدى النساء لا تزال
من البوهات هناك الكثير من من من
الكوميديين والكوميدي الذين يعملون على
على لا ادخال هذا الموضوع ضمن النكته لكي
يصبح مقبولا لدى المتلقي برايك هل يعني هل
انت تفكر بنفس الطريقه تعتبر ان بيدك ربما
سلاح للتغيير في مكان ما نعم لان نتكلم
على نتكلم على
شيء يولي اكستي
يي حاضر لي حاضر وعندما لا نتكلم عليه نف
لا
نرى وبالطبع انا
في
كان فنانات كوميديات يتكلمون على الدوره
الشهريه ونشوف باللي تزعج الناس كان بزاف
ناس منزعجين بهذا السؤال ا دائما عندما
نرى
امراه تكلم
تتكلم جنرالي تتكلم على الدوره الشقيه
وهذا هذا مشكل
ولان ارى ان في فرنسا الكوميديين
الرجال كل السنين الاخرى تكلموا عن
يتكلمون كثير
على
على على نفسهم وعمرها ما زعجت الناس ولكن
عندما على نفسها وعلى مشاكلها ا لان هناك
بزاف رجال ينزعجون من هذا وان اظن هذا
موضوع هام
جدا وربما ايضا يظهر الى اي مدى يمكن
للضحك ان يغير احيانا يعني في العقليات
طيب من اكبر البهات ربما واكثرها حساسيه
في مجتمعاتنا هي
الاديان نستمع الى ما قاله بهذا الخصوص
الكاتب والصحفي نصر الصيغ
ونعود المساله ليست في الدين المساله هي
في الممارسه وليس في العقيده الدينيه
والعقائد الدينيه لا تناقش لانها مسائل
ايمانيه الايمان لا يناقش يجب فصل الدين
عن النقاش بما له علاقه بالوقائع اليوميه
والسياسيه التي تعيشها المجتمعات في
مجتمعاتنا المراه ماساه كبرى عندنا شاد
فقيه تحدثتي منذ قليل عن الدين وعن يعني
كيف انت تقاربي هذه المساله اليوم عندما
تكتبين نصا
كوميديا هل تفصلين الدين عن النقاش
الايمان عن
النقاش وايضا اريد ان اعرف رايك بمساله
الدعابه التي تتناول الاديان الطوائف
العادات الدينيه هي موجوده في كل
المجتمعات بشكل عام
لماذا يعني هي ربما مكروهه او تقال على
صوت منخفض او في في الكواليس اوكي سو اول
شيء خلينا يعني انا لي كيف نظرتي للدين
الدين هو فلسفه هو
منه ديفاين يعني مشكلته للدين انه هو
محطوط تحت فكره انه هو مقدس انما انا بشوف
انه كل الاديان هي فلسفه ولكن لغيرك هو
مقدس كت على ديكارت لانه ديكارت لغير هو
مقدس لغيري هو مقدس بس كمان بغير اديان
البقره هي مقدسه طيب يعني بشي على كل قضس
الناس او انا يعني ايه ولكن عندما تكتبين
تكتبين لناس احيانا يكونون
مؤمنين
ايه طيب ماما اليوم كل بعتقد اللي قاله
اللي قاله هلا الانترفيو اللي رجيت توها
الفيديو قال شيء كثير حلو انه ما فيك
بالنقاش تحكي انت من منطلق دينه لانه
الدين ما فيه نقاش ام فاليوم انا اذا بدي
احكي عن مواضيع فكريا واسال اسئله ما في
اجي اقول لك انه بس هيدي هي الحقيقه
وحنمشي منها انا عم بجي اقول انا بدي افكر
بدي بدي ا فكك كل الافكار ما في ابلش من
حدا قال لي وجهه نظره للحقيقه انا لقلي
بدي اظهر م يعني مثلا عندما تكتبين عن
الاديان ليه اليوم المراه بدها تتحجب مثلا
ايه تكتبين عن كل الاديان بدون استثناء او
عن دين معين هل تمزحين او او تنكتين في
مسائل دينيه طبعا طبعا بنكت بمسائل دينيه
سبيشال القصص القمعيه يعني اللي بالاديان
اللي هي موجوده بكل الاديان بس اون انا
كوني خلقت انا
ب بالاسلام يعني كوني خلقت ستروبيا يعني
خلقت مسلمه هيدي كانت البيئه اللي حوالي
وانا عندي رده فعل اكثر شيء على ه البيئه
لانه هي اكثر شيء قمعت ني وللشخص المسيحي
بيئته هي اكثر شيء قمته ف اذا بدك النقد
انا بنتقد كل الاديان بس انا بحكي اكثر
شيء عن ديني اولا انت ما يكون نحن بتعرف
لبنان بلد طائفه بحكي عن كل الاديان ايكوي
يعني انا بجي بقول اوكي زعلنا الاسلام
خلينا نزعل المسيحيه هلا ت نزعل الكل
ايكوي عرفتي اي بس انا بحكي اكثر شيء عن
ديني لانه هو اكثر شيء اذان اللي هو انا
بعرفه اكثر شيء تحدثين عن العادات الدينيه
لكن ليس عن الامان كثير مهم تحكي عن يعني
تنتقدين العادات الدينيه ولكن ليس الايمان
الامان ما خصني فيه ام ام ام ام تمام عظيم
فقط يعني شو خص يعني شو خص الواحد
بالايمان يمكن الواحد بيشوف بسينه سودا
ويقول انه هيدي بتخوف وبيقعد بالبيت بس
انه واحد يشوف بسينه سوداء ويخافه ويقول
الكل فوتوا على البيت شيء ثاني سو هو مش
بس هو الايمان انت لك نعم بس انا لي
العقيده والعادات اللي طبقوها
وببرونات ونا فيها وبيهدد وبيحل دم في
بذاءه والشتيمه يا شادن ساتحدث عنها بعد
قليل البذاءه والشتيمه ساتحدث عنها بعد
قليل لانها
ت ولكن ولكن اريد ان اسال اسالك مصطفى في
مساله
الدين هناك خطوط حمراء موجوده اصلا يعني
في في بعض الدساتير في بعض الدول مساله
شتم او سب الذات الالهيه او الشخصيات
المقدسه ممنوع هل هذا الامر بالنسبه اليك
هو ربما رقابه او تعتبر انه من البديه انك
لا تدخل
في الفكاهه التي تقدمها بهذه الامور
بالنسبه لي بديهي انه انا ما ادخل في السب
والشتم يعني نفس البسين السب اللي بتتكلم
عنها او النقد ما بالضبط
يلا يعني بالنسبه لنا عشان تكون فنان يعني
اذا انت ما قدرت تتحرر من القيود اللي
قاعد فيها اصلا المجتمع وتطلع وتعاين
للمجتمع من بعيد هتعين للمجتمع زيك زي زول
قاعد جو المجتمع فالمجتمع ما حيستفيد شي
من نظرتك المختلفه لانها ما حتكون مختلفه
اصلا فبعد داك بالنسبه لمجتمع ض الكلام
اللي انت قلته او جب لله انت قلته يعني
النكته اللي انا عايز اقولها والرساله
اللي عايز اوصلها وصلت بعد ده كيف شال
المجتمع وكيف يتقبله ولا ما تقبله ويتعامل
معاه ويتعامل معاه او ما تعامل معاه دي
حاجه تخصه هو يعني هذا ينطبق على الدين
وعلى تبوها اخرى على كلها بالنسبه لي
بالنسبه لحريه هي الكلمه المفتاحيه اصلا
يعني اذا انا ما بقيت حر ما حقدر اقدم
الفن اللي انا بعمله بعد داك احتمال يجي
بعد 100 سنه يقوموا يشوفوا النكات اللي
انا قلت الليله وقها مضحكه ومفيده ويقوللك
مصطفى كان عنده نظره فتمام يعني طب
والشتيمه والبذاءه في النكات كيف تراها
كيف ت طبعا الكلام ده يعني اناس لما اقوله
هيعمل لي مشاكل كثيره خلاص
لكن بالنسبه لي يعني الكلمه البذيئه زيها
زي الكلمه اللي ما بذيئه ما بتفرق طالما
هي في الكونتكس يعني البذاءه لاجل البذاءه
بالنسبه لي زي الضحك لاجل الضحك يعني ما
في فايده لكن في مرات انت بتكون محتاج
بالجد ما هي الكلمه دي يعني ما اخترعناها
نحنا اعتباطا الكلمات كلها البذيئ
الاختراع معلش الاختراع البني ادم دي
اختراع لانه كان في حوجه ماسه لكلمه يقدر
يعبر في اللحظه دي وما لق غيرها لو لق
غيرها ما كان استعملها فبالنسبه لنا لو ما
لقيت كلمه غير الكلمه اللي انا عايز
اقولها او اول كلمه بتيجي في بالي عشان
اعبر بها دي هستعملها طوال يعني وطز
تمام اسماعيل برايك في البذاءه قبل ان
اعود الى شادن البذاءه في النكته يعني
هناك بعض الكوميديين والكوميدي يرفضون
مساله يعني الشتائم انت كيف تقارب هذه
المساله انا شخصيا اي
شخصيا ضد البداء والشتم في
النكت لان عندي
واحد العفه
نعم نفسي
ولكن يعني انت اصلا شخص لا تستخدم الشتائم
في حياتك اليوميه فبالتالي لا تستخدمها في
نصوصك طيب ولكن تراها مضحكه احيانا يعني
عندما تستمع الى نكات فيها بذاءه او شتائم
تضحك او لا بعد النكت نعم اراها مضحكه و
انا كين واحد كين واحد واحد الكوميدي
فرنسي كبير اسمه بير دي
بوش قال واحد الجمله نستطيع ان نضحك على
كل شيء ولكن ليس مع كل الناس نعم وان وانا
موافق معك كثير في هذ
الجمله وسمم يكون ك واحد
الاينس شباب ونظن مع الشباب نج نستقبل
نستقبل الفكره هناك ربما تلقائيه اكثر او
راحه اكبر في في استخدام اللغه
الرائجه حضرات نلعب قدام جمهور و كاين
عائلات
وكاين نعود الى فكره الجمهور يعني من هو
الجمهور طيب شادن انت يعني مشهوره
بمساله الشتيمه او البذاءه في النكه
تستخدمينها بكل اريحيه وتدافع عنها كيف
يعني اشرحي هذه الفكره انا بدي اسالك سؤال
ساعتها ما يسالون انه انت بتسبي يعني هو
قلب الادوار غير مسموح في هذه في هذا
البرنامج ولكن مش على الهواء ولكن ولكن مش
على الهواء مش على الهواء انت بالبيت يعني
ممكن انت امك معصبه
بتسب امك
بتسب لا للامانه امي مثل اسماعيل مثل
اسماعيل امي عندها الكثير من العفه لا
تشتم ولكن هناك ناس تشتم طبعا اكيد في
المجتمع هناك ناس تشتم الله يرحم
وانت جاوبيني المجتمع كله بب حتى امك لما
لما انت لما لما تعملي شيء غلط انت مثلا
انه
طبخ حسبك وتسب التبر نعم ولكن هناك كما
قال منذ
قليل كونتكست يعني هناك يعني وضع وضعيه ما
قد تدفع بالشخص الى الشتم في الحياه
الطبيعيه انت فنانه تقفين على المسرح و
تقدمين نصا فيه شتائم يعني يمكن ان تتحكمي
بهذا الامر لماذا اخترتي هذه الطريقه هذا
سؤالي خليني
انا انا لي برجع للفكره اللي قلتها من
الاساس انه انا لي ما بمثل انا لي انا
يعني انا شو بفكر وكيف بقولوا شو بسال
بقولهم على العالي اليوم انت بالسياره
ببيروت علقانه بعج سير بتسب الدنيا كلها
وكل هول نحن بلغتنا ونحن سبيشل بلبنان
يعني نحن كثير بنسب يعني هو شعب سب عادي
عرفتي فجاه بصيروا وقتها يحضروك وانا
المسبه مش هي الكوميدي انا الفكره هي
الكوميدي المسبه هي تعبير يعني انت لما ن
تعصبي يعني نحن اليوم معل ما فيش مسبات
كافيه بلبنان ام تتحكي عن السلطه السياسيه
والسياسات اللي بلبنان موجوده فانا اليوم
كمان جزء من تعبيري هو الغضب والغضب مثل
ما قال زميلنا الكوميدي انه نحن يعني
اخترع الانسان هالطريقه لانه امرار بيكون
غضبان بطريقه مش عار يقول يعني ف عن الغ
مش هي اللي بتضحك الفكره هي اللي بتضحك
نعم هي جزء من السيناريو يعني هي جزء من
السيناريو تعتبرينه واقعيا لا لا انا يعني
انا لست هنا لاجد لك في مساله الشتم انا
فقط اريد ان افهم لماذا تستخدمين هذه
اللغه وقد
فهمنا يعني هذا الراي طيب حت تحدث اليوميه
بلا اخلاق يعني تحدثتي عن الغضب تقولي نحن
ققول لي بلا اخلاق بس ما انت بدك تحكي
فعلا عن الاخلاق ما هي الاخلاق يعني
الاخلاق هي انت كيف تتصرف بالمجتمع انا
اذا سبيت ما يعني انا بالاخلاق انا اذا
سبيت حدا عم يقمع ما يعني بالاخلاق انا
اذا سبيت العنصريه ما يعني انا باللا
اخلاق الاخلاق هي بالافكار بالقيم نعم مش
بالكلام التعصيب حق والكلام البذيء حق وكل
الناس
بتقوله للاسف بتقول انت كلمه فجاه هن
بتنزل العفه عليهم وانه ما بيحكو هيك شو
طيب ياتي هذا الامر من الغضب تحدثتي قلت
غضبانه غاضبين وهذا امر ملفت جدا خاصه في
الجيل الجديد من الكوميديات والكوميدي في
العالم العربي مصطفى
هناك قيل هناك الثوره في النكه الساخره
لتخفيف مراره الواقع يعني اليوم هناك واقع
ربما قاسي وعنيف وتاتي
الفكاهه لتخفف من مرارته وتكسر ربما
المكبوت الي مدى هذا صحيح وهل انت تشعر
ضمنيا ان هناك ربما غضب ما تعبر عنه
بابتسامه او او بنص
مضحك جدا 100% يعني زي ما قلت لك قبل شويه
انه انا يعني يعني انا قمت في بلد شاف
سلام متواصل لمده لا تتخطى الاربع شهور
تمام قمت فيه وك ده اول ما شفت الدنيا
عملنا ثوره وخلاص يعني قررنا نغير الحكومه
اللي قاعده لها 30 سنه بعدها بسنتين حصل
انقلاب طلعنا انا من السودان جيت هنا هه
حاليا من شهر اربعه بدات فيه حرب يعني
الاحداث المتواصله في حياتك هي عباره عن
يعني مقاسي مقاسي ماسي مقاسي
اس اسمه شنو الفنانه اللي كان بتعمل لي
الميك اب قبل قبل الحلقه قالت لي انه انت
انا يعني ما متخيل انه في السودان يكون في
كوميديا او السودان بلد انت تقوم انه تبقى
كوميدي يعني قلت لها بالعكس يعني اصلا انا
في السودان لو ما كنت بجيت كوميدي كان قطع
رازي يعني يعني ما ما كان ما كان في يكون
في خيارات يعني يعني هي هذه ربما الفكاهه
التي تاتي من من من مرا من رحم المعاناه
بالضبط رح المعاناه مليون في الم يعني طيب
ما بتخير نفسي لو كنت غاني كان ممكن اكون
مضحك اسماعيل توافق يلا ساعطيك الكلمه شاد
اسماعيل توافق على هذه الفكره انه يعني
المعاناه تولد احيانا حاجه اكبر الى الى
الى تقديم الواقع بطريقه
مضحكه نعم وتساعد بزاف ناس انا في فرنسا
اتكلم كثير على الراسم اللي تعيشه
الاقليات العرب فارقه وعندما نتكلم على
هذا الشي ج ك بزاف ناس يج يتكلموا
مضحكنا على هذا الشيء
وحس جيد اتكلم
قريشن بفتره كت فيبريشن واتكلم عل
الكوميديا وارى ال
الناس
تتفاعل نعم لانه اصلا الكوميديا تمكنت
ايضا من كسر تبول الامراض النفسيه او
مشاكل الاكتئاب لانه يعني هذا تبوء ايضا
في المجتمعات الناس عاده لا تتحدث عنه
الصحه النفسيه طيب شادن ماذا تريدين ان
تقولي قبل ان انتقل الى الفكره الاخيره
تفضلي انه انا انا بعتبر مثلا بواقع
الحياه الواقع السياسي بمناطقنا الوحشه
العنيف
بكل هول الامور انا لي ما بعرف شو كنت
عملت يعني ما بعرف الناس اللي ما بتعمل
ستاند اب كوميدي كيف قادره تضلها تعيش وما
عم تحكي بهالامور فانا اليوم انه الستاند
اب عم تنقذني من من ماي عم تفيد ما من
صحتي النفسيه لانه انا بعتبر حالي انا كيف
يعني عم بصير كل هال خراب وهالو حشيه
بحياتنا وما احكي وانا انظلم وما احكي
واتعرض وما احكي وغيري يتعرض وانا ما احكي
فيها جنون ف اليوم الكوميدي انا لي هي
وسيله ت انا اجي اطلع كل هول ت انا ابقى
يعني ولو جزء انا باخذ قدي اعصاب انتبهي
يعني انا مش صا انت تحافظين على على قليل
من العقلانيه لانه على القليله وقت عم
بيصير كل هال القصص انا مش بس عم بصير وعم
بتلقى ومش عم بعمل شيء وقت انا احمل سلاح
الكوميديا انا عم بعمل شيء اذا انا ما عم
بعمل شيء يعني انا شو عم بعمل انا عم
بتلقى وما عم حارب فانا بعتقد انه هيدا
بينقذ ني بينقذ ني من عده امور طيب شاد
قبل الختام سنستمع معك ومع ضيفين الى ما
قاله الفيلسوف والناشط الحقوقي احمد عصيد
عن مساله التعاطف الانتقائي التي تعود الى
الواجهه خاصه مع اندلاع النزاعات المسلحه
او الكوارث الطبيعيه دعونا
نستمع منذ الاعلان عن المبادئ الكبرى
لحقوق الانسان منذ 48 اصبح المفهوم الكوني
للانسان لكن له جذور في فلسفه الانوار منذ
القرن ال عندما كتب ايمانويل كانت بان
الانسان كرامه لانه غايه في ذاته ولا يمكن
ان يكون وسيله تقضى به اغراض اخرى منذ هذا
التعريف اصبح مفهوم التضامن الانساني يشمل
كل البشر باعتبار ان الانسان
جوهر يعني متعالي على الموجودات الاخرى
وبالتالي ينبغي ان تعطاه قيمته من حيث هو
انسان بغض النظر عن عقيده او لونه او عرقه
اوسب العائلي او لسانه ولغته او اصله ال
الى غير ذلك وطبعا التضامن الانساني هنا
ينبغي ان يجعلنا نتضامن مع كل انسان
مظلوم كلمه اخيره معك ابدا اسماعيل القيم
الانسانيه كونيه كما قال ضيفنا وكذلك
الضحك هو كوني برايك هل يمكن ان نضحك على
كل شيء كما قلت يمكن ان نضحك على كل شيء
ولكني مع كل الناس
ولازم يكون عندنا دقه عندما نتكلم على
موضوع حساس نعم و شكرا لك
مصطفى نضحك على كل شيء
اضحك قو يمكن ان نضحك على كل شيء ولكن ليس
باي طريقه وعاز ممكن استغل الفرصه الاخيره
اللي اديتني لها دي في انه انا اطرحها على
الناس اللي بتموت كل يوم في السودان واقول
للناس يعني يشوفوا يفتشوا اللي حاصل شنو
في السودان لانه قاعد يحرق يعني
شكرا لك يا مصطفى شادن كلمه اخيره كلمه
اخيره انه انا مع كل الوسائل ان كانت
الكوميديا الكتابه الفن اي نوع
للمقاومه المقاومه مثل ما عم يعملوا يعني
المقاومه على الحروب على الوحشيه على
العنصريه على كل ه وما في مقاومه يعني
فرديه نحن كلنا مع بعض اليوم اذا بفلسطين
وسودان عم ين ق انا ما في اكون ساكته ام
واذا انا عم بنقتل ما فيكم انتم تكونوا
ساكتين يعني برجع لفكره انه مي حره غير
للكل يكون حر وسبلي انه يعني انا كمرا
كواريه بقلب لبنان كل هول
يعني ياما حاسين حالنا لحالنا
بمعارك وانا ما بدي احسس حدا انه هو لحاله
بالمعركه بالعكس بدي اجي اقول لحلا حدا
انا معك بالمعركه وانت معي بالمعركه طيب
هل انت مع الضحك من دون سبب نعم ام لا
العالم البشع شيء حلو شادن انت مع الضحك
بلا سبب ام لاو انت مع الضحك بلا سبب ام
لا انا مع الضحك بس مش على حساب الثانيين
الضحك حلو السعاده حلوه والضحك امرار بيجي
باسوا يعني بالدفن بيجي امرار هو حاجه
انسانيه شكرا شكرا لك وشكرا لضيفنا مصطفى
واسماعيل يعني تبادل الابتسامات والقه
قهات هو تعبير عن الحريه وعن المشاعر
الايجابيه و مع نهايه هذا العام نتمنى
لكننا ولكم لحظات يملاها الضحك واياما
تزينها القهقهه والنقاش في فرك الممنوع لا
نهايه له برنامجنا يعود قريبا بموسم جديد
وتبوت جديده دائما على شاشه فرانس ك واثير
اذاعه مونت كارلو الدوليه
[موسيقى]
تحياتي